aversa et quelques dizaines de personnes
sont venues écouter les mots de jean luc
romero le président de l'association
pour le droit à mourir dans la dignité
en france l'euthanasie reste illégal
mais la dernière loi clé leonetti
autorise l'arrêt des traitements et une
mise sous sédation profonde du patient
une avancée encore insuffisantes pour
jean luc romero
on vous endort vous n'avez jamais vous
réveiller on arrête de vous alimentez on
arrête de vous hydrater vous pouvez
mettre trois semaines à mourir alors que
nous nous demandons que la personne
puisse partir en quelques secondes
entouré des siens après l'avoir dé
revoir plutôt que d'avoir ce longtemps
d'agonie dont on ne voit pas du tout le
sens sur ce dossier les législateurs se
montre plus prudente la population selon
un sondage 80 % des français seraient
favorables à l'euthanasie dans la
nouvelle loi clay leonetti les volontés
des patients écrite au préalable doivent
être respectées par les médecins mais là
encore l'association veut aller plus
loin
les directives anticipées sont possibles
dans notre pays le seul problème c'est
qu'elles ne sont pas obligatoires pour
les médecins et c'est pour ça que nous
on se bat pour que ce que vous écriviez
quand vous avez en plus toute la
connaissance de cause toute la capacité
ce soit obligatoire et que les médecins
soient obligés de de faire ce que vous
demandez beaucoup de personnes dans
l'assemblée sont concernés par ces
questions
l'une d'elles a tenu à remercier le
président pour son soutien dans une
affaire personnelle
nous on attend du nouveau gouvernement
qui changent enfin de logique pour
l'instant on a fait des lois sur les
devoirs des médecins vers toutes ces
lois ont été confiés à des médecins
c'est pas une affaire médicale c'est une
affaire citoyenne
on veut une loi qui place enfin celui
qui meurt au centre de la décision pas
sûr que les choses bougent le candidat
emmanuel macron s'était prononcé en
faveur du maintien de la législation
actuelle